this is a critical week for britain's
prince andrew in his legal efforts to
avoid fallout from the jeffrey epstein's
sexual abuse scandal just days after the
conviction of epstein associate gallane
maxwell a new york judge today will
unseal a confidential agreement between
epstein and one of his accusers which
the prince's lawyers say could shield
him from a civil sexual abuse lawsuit
prince andrew's attorneys call that
lawsuit baseless and they are trying to
get it dismissed tomorrow holly williams
has more on the story from london
on christmas day at windsor castle as
other royals went to church prince
andrew was nowhere to be seen
tarnished by his friendship with
convicted child sex offenders jeffrey
epstein and glenn maxwell the prince is
liked by just six percent of the british
public according to a recent poll
and the queen's second son is no longer
performing royal duties
andrew has been pushed right to the
sides and told you're not representing
anything we don't want you dressing up
keep the hell out of it kelvin mckenzie
is the former editor of a british
tabloid newspaper the sun
if the sexual assault lawsuit against
prince andrew goes ahead he told us the
media coverage will be a royal
embarrassment
will be beyond shocking he will be
slaughtered prince andrew should be
panicking his accuser virginia roberts
jaffrey claims she was trafficked to
prince andrew for sex by epstein and
maxwell when she was 17 years old she
told gail king in 2020 she wants justice
he needs to be held accountable we need
to show the world that
the rich and the mighty can fall too
the prince denies the accusation and
says he has no recollection of ever
meeting roberts duffrey he has never
been charged with any criminal offence
but legal analyst joe tamborino told us
in the civil suit brought by roberts
jeffrey demanding unspecified financial
damages the standard of proof is lower
if she proves more than 50
she wins if she doesn't prove more than
50
she loses if the trial goes ahead the
prince faces a deposition gulen maxwell
could be called as a witness and an
attorney for roberts jeffrey says they
also want to depose megan duchess of
sussex all of it promising more dirty
royal laundry does she have any factual
information of being part of even
briefly the royal family and have any
information on prince andrew how he
acted what he was like where he was at
certain times so on and so forth the
prince brought epstein into the heart of
the royal family even appearing at his
daughter's 18th birthday costume party
alongside glenn maxwell and harvey
weinstein and i took the decision in
2019 he tried to explain his behavior in
a bbc interview including this
justification for staying at epstein's
new york mansion after he'd been
imprisoned on child sex charges
but you were staying at the house of a
convicted sex offender
it was a convenient place to stay calvin
mckenzie believes that regardless of the
lawsuit's result the prince's reputation
will never recover if the tabloid were
the jury he'd be doing ten years now is
the truth they've found him guilty
that's it
for cbs mornings holly williams london
yeah it doesn't get any worse than six
percent of the public considers you
persona non grata yeah although i will
say i don't want the tabloid to be the
jury i mean an actual jury no but kudos
to virginia guffrey who continues to
speak up and you see they take great
pains to make sure andrew's never in a
shot with the queen